let's try mark from new jersey instead
mark from
jersey you're on the air hey david how
are you
i'm doing very well awesome so i was
wondering uh you know in today's
current vaccine situation there's a lot
of misinformation that's preventing
people from getting vaccines but do you
think a positive
misinformation campaign could lead to a
good result something like you know
having bald guys say oh it helped me
regrow my hair and things like that
almost knee status so um no i mean
so the answer is yes it might work i
mean listen the people who buy the
supplements the people who
do all the crazy you know if you're if
you would fall for that
they probably would at least some of
them fall for you know the vaccine
regrew my hair uh gave me muscle mass
and works like uh
you know an erectile dysfunction pill or
whatever right i'm
sure it would convince some people but i
don't think it's a great idea
would i what i would be more okay with
would be something like
calling it trump juice and marketing it
like a soda
and i as i tweeted i think that would
get some republicans on board
i tweeted about this earlier this week
and a lot of people
latched on to it they thought it was a
good idea start spreading the rumor
that democrats are glad republicans
aren't getting vaccinated
because that means they're going to die
and then maybe republicans would be like
screw you watch me go and get vaccinated
like
that but but straight up lies like it'll
regrow hair
i i wouldn't be on board with yeah so
i know people were saying uh uh bill
gates is going to mind control people
but if they framed it where
the vaccine protects you from bill gates
mind control you know something like
that
i totally know what you're saying i
totally know what you're saying it would
work for some people i would just be
listen
i think it would be more benign to just
hey promote it as the trump vaccine
if you if that's what you believe trump
made the vaccine and trump took the
vaccine
be like trump i think that would
basically work as well as the regrow
hair thing
and it feels less obviously dishonest
although it's still dishonest but
in a less uh empirically uh
concerning way right awesome thanks man
my pleasure my pleasure yeah there's a
lot of work to be done there that's for
sure
uh gotta figure out what what will work
with these people